[Music]
thank you
and it's not just politicians in the US
that are uninspiring these days in this
week's magazine Douglas Murray lambasts
the culture of kankaking that British
politics has got itself inji we seem to
be report heavy and action-like he
writes
so Douglas welcome back to spectator TV
um as soon as the new column this week
that there are two problems you're
picking up on the first is this culture
of just commissioning reports and
they're not really doing anything with
them and the second is what's happening
with the prevent strategy and how we can
fix it can we talk about that first one
first what is this culture that British
politics has got itself into where there
are just millions of reports but nothing
ever gets done
yes it's very strange I I say in my
column this week that it you could argue
it started with the coalition government
from 2010 to 2015. where the
conservative and liberal Democrats you
know had a lot they didn't agree on the
easiest way to not uh upset Nick Clegg
which was obviously in those years as we
know the absolute priority okay
um was was to kick things into
commissions inquiries reports uh
judicial overviews of things
um that way effective you didn't have to
decide anything remember for instance
that the energy problems that we have in
our country at the moment could actually
be remedied if it wasn't for the fact
that that coalition government just
endlessly sort of kicked things into the
long grass into reporting stages I mean
I wrote about this recently but you know
and I don't sound like I am picking on
him but well I am but Nick Clegg uh said
at the beginning of the Coalition you
know if if we did this new nuclear
reactor you know the the energy wouldn't
even come online until like 2022 2023 I
mean wow who could expect such a date to
ever arrive
um and actually it turns out you know we
could have done with decisions being
made on our energy at that point we
could have done with with with
questions like that in the National
interest not just being endlessly farmed
out to to commissions to reports to
inquiries and so on but somehow that
became the culture in Whitehall and even
when the conservatives got a majority
uh in 2015. that culture continued I
give the example in the column of the
Louise Casey review they looked into the
problems of integration in the UK I
admire Louise Casey very much I spoke to
her when she was doing that review
um and uh and a fine piece of work it is
but effectively the government said
thank you very much for delivering your
report and then and then shelved it
um nothing has happened so far as I can
see actually no no no deliverables to
use one of the ugly terms of government
about the Casey review and and you can
just see that on in case after case
we've We've Ended up with this sort of
government situation where something
happens and they say something must be
done and the something is a report that
will report at some point in the coming
years and then we don't have to listen
to it well to be fair I mean just going
back to Nick like maybe he already knew
that he wouldn't be in Westminster for
another 10 years
yes it seemed like an implausibly long
timeline for him
um and just just on these reports and do
you think the problem is that there's no
no eagle or moral political obligation
for government act on these reports once
they're commissioned and published as
you say they can just be shelved always
said that the reports themselves are
often not the right solution they don't
identify the problems well there
shouldn't be I mean you can't commission
a report and then say it's going to be
legally binding or a commission of
inquiry and say it's got to be legally
binding that that would be even more
impossible no I I think the problem is
just that there that there is no
political will to make decisions the
fact is is that when certain decisions
come across the prime minister's desk or
a Home secretary's desk they just have
to make the decision one way or the
other uh and as they say somehow we've
got stuck in this culture which is it's
just easier to farm it out it's easier
to kick a can along the road like why
um to get on to the the second part of
what you know what we're discussing the
prevent issue like why after the three
terrorist attacks in 2017 including the
London Bridge attack or London Bridge
one as it became known why did Theresa
may need to say enough is enough okay
sure like nobody loves seeing school
girls blown up at a concert in
Manchester okay great enough is enough
what are you going to do about it prime
minister I'm going to appoint a
commissioner to look into the question
of extremism and then work on it for
years what happened I admire Sarah Khan
who was actually appointed as
commissioner but what happens is the
prime minister says all these people
have been killed in British cities in
London and Manchester and uh as a result
I'm going to commission an eminently
um you know suitable figure to look into
the problem of extremism what happens
that person takes years to for instance
at the beginning Define what extremism
might be
you know like when the London Bridge
attackers were slitting people's throats
on London Bridge in 2017 I mean I
imagine I don't want to speak for them
obviously or try to I imagine that
they've been surprised if they thought
that the response to this by government
would be a hermeneutical inquiry into
the nature of the term extremism
or a request to academics across the UK
to send in academic papers about areas
to do with extremism and radicalization
within the UK and then for that to go on
for years and years you know I mean it's
just not it's not a way to govern it's a
weak way to govern sure that's what
Theresa May demonstrated then just as
some of her predecessors had and that's
what I worry about with the the issue
which is sort of the culmination point I
try to make in the column this week
yes well let's bring in that report
because there's another report stuck in
the White Hall pipes at the moment all
about extremism and terrorism tell us
about the shore cross report
yes uh well in the wake of the seven
seven bombies way back in 2005 uh the
Blair government instituted the prevent
strategy it was intended to uh address
issues of de-radicalization of
radicalization to try to identify people
who might be of interest it were just
before they come to the interest of the
security services or the police it was
highly controversial particularly within
the Muslim Community because a lot of
Muslim Community leaders said ah you're
targeting the Muslim Community and much
more and there has been a massive amount
of disinformation Pumped out about
prevent by primarily so-called leaders
in the Muslim Community who have
terrified the Muslim Indians what this
actually means
um the prevent strategy has metastasized
over the years again rather like Sarah
Khan report you get this thing of sort
of new
um well it's unfair just to look into
the people who are doing suicide
bombings why don't we look into other
types of extremism as well and I give an
example in the article that by now
prevent actually and you've probably got
the quote in front of you uh actually I
mean it's worth reading out what about
that definition if I can ask you if they
haven't got in front of me one of the
definite definitions of extremism of
prevent of cultural nationalism as the
ideology which is a belief that Western
culture is under threat from Mass
migration into Europe and from a lack of
integration by certain ethnic and
cultural groups and that is one of the
ideologies that they are tackling as
mathematics so so so so prevent now or
in recent years has both covered as it
were the victim of terrorism and the
terrorists in the same smorge Board of
allegations if if you're the per if
you're the young man who left a bomb on
the Underground trailer Parsons Green a
few years ago an illegal migrant who
shouldn't have been in the U UK and made
a bomb and left it on a train if you're
that then you're a subject of interest
to prevent but also if say you were one
of the people on that train at Parsons
Green that morning who thought hey I'm
not that cool about people just walking
into my country making bombs and leaving
them on my underground train in the
morning well you're also a potential
subject of interest to prevent and that
that has been the problem of prevent the
metastasizing of it so the Boris Johnson
government remember him a commissioned a
review in to prevent perfectly suitable
to do it William shawcross the former
head of the charity commission a very
distinguished author and public servant
who was asked to do the review it was
delivered last summer when a pretty
Patel was Home Secretary remember her
you know this is how long ago we're
talking about in all these processes the
reports continue the inquiries continue
but Prime Ministers and home secretaries
come and go
um it was delivered last summer and it
is meant to be released fairly soon but
there's just been this blockage in the
system because the system is busily just
debating the report that the system had
asked for and we're no closer to
addressing any of the questions though
than we were when Boris Johnson first
commissioned Shaw cross Douglas I wonder
if you've seen this reporting that I saw
about why there's a holder which is that
uh the home office has advice and
redactions of names of groups and
individuals uh in through in this report
and the reporting seemed to be that Sue
Ella braveman a Home Secretary is taking
those reductions whereas Michael Gove is
pushing back and saying that we need
these names out there I don't think that
is how accurate that is to what is
happening behind the scenes but it seems
bizarre that Braverman who is isn't she
meant to be a bit of a bulldog in
defense of British values and very
difficult on terrorism if if the
reporting is true it's very
disappointing about the homer secretary
very disappointing indeed
um yes the report has been in the system
so long now that there has been
significant briefing of the reporters so
we all know what it says yes I mean it's
been leaked to every paper from the
telegraph to the guardian in in segments
uh by by obviously officials in the home
office
um uh many of whom will be will be
worried about the the prevent review
because they'll be worried about the end
of the boondoggle of of massive spigots
of public spending that reassure them
that they can spend their days sitting
at a desk chewing a pen pretending to
worry about what definition of extremism
we should use in the UK and so on but
anyway there's been lots of leaks one of
the leaks as you say is there is this
this hold up and it would be very very
disturbing if it was the case that the
Home Secretary or anyone else in
government was worried genuinely worried
about the naming of individuals in this
this report and it comes back to the
source of the problem what what the hell
is the point of commissioning work
looking into serious problems when in
the end of the process and at the end of
the process
officials are worried about upsetting
the feelings of extremists actual
extremists islamists in the UK what the
hell is the point of all of these
reports where even when you get to the
point in question you end up with
officials saying well we can't upset the
islamists can we well the awful thing
that would be um
Douglas Murray thank you for joining
spectator TV
great pleasure as always
[Music]